♪.
JASON: THE ILLINOIS STATE SENATE
FACING BACKLASH FOR REQUESTING A
WHOPPING $41.6 BILLION FEDERAL
BAILOUT, AS THE STATE’S
FINANCIAL TROUBLES CONTINUE TO
GROW AMID THE CORONAVIRUS
OUTBREAK.
"THE CHICAGO TRIBUNE" EDITORIAL
BOARD CALLING THE REQUEST
SHAMELESS AND DISHONEST.
OUR NEXT GUEST AGREES.
SAYING LIBERAL POLICIES ARE
RUINING IS HAD STATE.
JOINING AMERICA FIRST NATIONAL
SPOKESPERSON STEVE CORTEZ.
STEVE, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
THIS REALLY IS GROTESQUE.
FOR THE ILLINOIS STATE SENATE TO
REQUEST $41 BILLION FROM US
FEDERAL TAXPAYERS TO BAIL THEM
OUT, NOT JUST FOR CORONAVIRUS
BUT FOR A WHOLE LOT MORE.
>> RIGHT.
SHAMELESS IS REALLY THE
WATCHWORD UNFORTUNATELY.
AND THE POLITICIANS THAT ARE
RUINING THIS CITY OF CHICAGO AND
STATE OF ILLINOIS, THEY BELIEVE
IN THIS MOMENT OF CRISIS, THEY
FOUND A BEARD, A WAY TO MASK
WHAT IS A FINANCIAL DISASTER IN
THE STATE, INCLUDED IN THE
40 BILLION JASON, THEY ASKED FOR
$10 BILLION JUST TO BAIL OUT THE
UNFUNDED PENSION OBLIGATIONS.
THOSE EXISTED WELL BEFORE THE
VIRUS EVER HIT IN THE UNITED
STATES INCLUDING ILLINOIS.
HERE IS THE REAL ISSUE.
IT IS THE SPENDING BY STATE OF
ILLINOIS, PARTICULARLY COMES TO
EMPLOYEES AND PENSION
OBLIGATIONS.
RIGHT NOW IN ILLINOIS, ACCORDING
TO OPEN THE BOOKS, WE HAVE
100,000 EMPLOYEES OR RETIREES
ARE MAKING $100,000 PLUS IN THIS
STATE.
TO GIVE YOU ONE PARTICULARLY
ENGREEN JUST EXAMPLE, PARK
FOREST, ILLINOIS, WHERE I GREW
UP, MY HOMETOWN, A BLUE SUBURB
OF CHICAGO, JUST RETIRED
SUPERINTENDENT OF ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS, JOYCE MADE $400,000 IN
THE FINAL YEARS, AND WILL MAKE
$300,000 FOR THE REST OF HER
LIFE.
IN A BLUE-COLLAR COMMUNITY WHERE
THE AVERAGE HOME PRICE IS ONLY
$75,000.
THAT RECKLESS SPENDING MADE
ILLINOIS’S INTO AMERICA’S GREECE
AND DEBT AND FINANCIAL WOES
WITHOUT THE SUNSHINE AND
ISLANDS, UNFORTUNATELY, JASON.
JASON: LOOK, HERE IS WHAT "THE
CHICAGO TRIBUNE" SAID, AND I
QUOTE, IT IS NOT SURPRISING IN
ILLINOIS POLITICIAN FINALLY PUT
IN WRITING WHAT ECONOMISTS AND
FINANCIAL WATCHDOGS HAVE BEEN
WARNING FOR YEARS, THAT ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHO FAILED TO TAKE
SERIOUSLY DECADES OF FISCAL
WARNING BELLS IN THE STATE
EVENTUALLY WOULD SEEK A BAILOUT
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WHAT IS BEYOND GALLING IS USING
THE CORONAVIRUS AS AN EXCUSE.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, WHEN I WAS IN
CONGRESS A FEW YEARS, WE
HIGHLIGHTED THIS BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS NOT JUST
ILLINOIS.
YOU HAVE PLACES LIKE PHOENIX,
ARIZONA, CALIFORNIA, NEW JERSEY,
WHO YOU’RE RIGHT, IT IS A
MULTITRILLION DOLLAR PROBLEM
WHERE THEY PROMISED ALL OF THESE
RETIREMENT BENEFITS BUT THEY
HAVEN’T GOT THE MONEY TO
ACTUALLY PAY THEM.
>> RIGHT.
JASON, LOOK, I THINK IT IT IS
CLEAR THAT THESE DEMOCRAT-LED
STATES THEY ARE BANKING ON,
HOPING FOR A FEDERAL BAILOUT.
THEY BELIEVE IN DONALD TRUMP
WERE TO LOOSE IN NOVEMBER WHICH
IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN, IF THEY
BELIEVE THAT WOULD HAPPEN,
EVENTUALLY FLIP THE SENATE, THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD
FEDERALIZE ALL THESE PROBLEMS
FROM THE PROFLIGATE BLUE STATES.
NONE OF THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN, SHOULD HAPPEN,
WHAT SPEAKER, EXCUSE ME, LEADER
McCONNELL SAID HE ARTICULATED
WE NEED TO CHANGE FEDERAL LAWS
AND FEDERAL POLICIES TO ALLOW
BANKRUPTCIES FOR STATES LIKE
ILLINOIS THAT IS THE ONLY
REASONABLE SOLUTION.
JASON: THEY WILL HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IT, BECAUSE IT IS A
MULTITRILLION DOLLAR PROBLEM.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN PRINT
MONEY, BUT STATES, COUNTIES,
CITIES, THEY CAN’T.